[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
في حصيله الفادحه وفي سابقه الدفاع
الروسيه تعلن عن مقتل 63 جنديا بهجوم
اوكرانيه على معسكر تجنيد
السلطات الايرانيه تلجا للاعتقالات واحكام
الاعدام لترهيب المحتاجين وفتاه تتحدى
الامن بمنطقه كرديه
المجلس الاعلى للدوله في ليبيا يقرر
استئناف الحوار مع البرلمان ودبيبه يهاجم
خصومه السياسيين
عوده الحياه لمدن صينيه بعد تخفيف اجراءات
الكورونا وعدد متزايد من الدول يفرد قيودا
على القادمين من الصين
اذا مشاهدينا نبدا الخامسه من هذه
التصريحات غير المسبوقه لوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اعلنت مقتل ثلاثه 63 مجندا بهجوم
اوكراني على معسكر تجنيد مؤقت في منطقه
شرقي اوكرانيا الوزاره ذكرت ان الهجوم
الاوكراني تم تنفيذه بالصواريخ هامرز
شديده الانفجار وان الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت
اثنين منها
ومشاهدينا طبعا هذه الصور وصلتنا قبل قليل
لموقع هذا الهجوم نشاهد دمار كبير وطبعا
اعداد القتلى كما ذكرنا قبل قليل وهذا
بحسب التصريحات الروسيه لوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه نتحدث عن 36
مجنه قتلوا من خلال هذا الاستهداف تم طبعا
الاستهداف
من خلال استخدام اسلحه شديده الانفجار
وهمم الجانب الروسي يتحدث عن ان الدفاعات
الجويه اسقطت اثنين من الصواريخ التي تمت
همم تم
ارسالها واطلاقها باتجاه هذا المعسكر
على كل المزيد معنا من اكياب مراسل
العربيه حذيفه عادل اهلا بك من موسكو عبد
الجواد الرشد مراسل العربيه ايضا اهلا بيك
ومن دونيسك نحيي مراسلنا رائد الاغبر
ونبدا به لنعرف المزيد حول هذا الاستهداف
رائد
يعني الايام الاخيره ثلاثه ايام كانت
معاركها ضاريه القصف شديد ولا يتوقف على
كل انحاء المقاطع والمدينه هنا مدينه
ثانيه
يعني حدثت فيها الضربه الاخرانيه فعلا
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع عن مقتل 63 جندي كانت
هي من اكبر الضربات التي طلقتها روسيا همم
كما اسلافي صواريخ
الاسلحه الاوروبيه والامريكيه التي تصل
بيد القوات الاوكرانيه بالفعل هي يعني
تغير مسرى ومسار المعارك بالفعل هناك
اسلحه تشيكيه وبولنديه وصلت تطلق من
راجمات صواريخ صواريخ همم بامبير عفوا هذه
الصواريخ الحديثه التي بدات تستخدم وتسقط
في جميع انحاء المدينه
تعرضنا ليله امس للقذف على بعد امتار
ميسون فرعنا الى اقرب ملكه
عامه ولكن الحمد لله على سلامتكم ولكن لا
شك بانه استهداف مثل هذا المعسكر له
دلالات كبيره خبرنا ان كان لديك معلومات
اوفا نتحدث فيها عن ربما المنطقه عن
المعسكر نفسه وكيف لم تستطع الدفاعات
الروسيه الا اسقاط اثنين من الصواريخ فقط
ميسون القواعد العسكريه الروسيه هي تكون
بعيده عن مناطق المدنيين حيث ان
المدنيين او حتى نحن العاملين في الصحافه
لا يسمح لنا من وصول الى المناطق العسكريه
فنحن بالفعل بعيدين عن هذا الحدث وسنذهب
للتغطيه بعد قليل لنرى ما هي اخر الاحداث
لكن الحقيقه بان القصف لا يستهدف فقط
العسكريين هذه المره اعلنت الدفاع الروسيه
عن اعداد القتلى هناك بشكل يومي ضحايا عند
الطرفين الجيش الروسي والجيش الاوكراني
واعلنت الدفاع الروسيه انه ثوره حدوث هذه
الضربه رده القوات الروسيه على مدينه
كرامته ويعني خلف القصف الروسي مئات
الضحايا من الجانب
الاخرانيات عسكريه كثيره
او روايه الجانب الاوكراني ان كان فيما
يتعلق بهذا الاستهداف او حتى الرد الروسي
تفضل الحذيفه
طبعا الرقم بحسب الجيش الاوكراني هو 670
جنديا روسيا تم تحديدهم في هجمه صاروخيه
وضربه نفذها الجيش الاوكراني هذا من جانب
طبعا
670 اييه مجلد داخل هذا المعسكر او بصوره
عامه في المنطقه
نعم فقط حددت ان في في الهجوم الذي تم
تنفيذه في مكيف كتحديدا
استطاعت القوات الاوكرانيه ان تحيد 670
جنديا روسيا وليس على خطوط القتال بشكل
عام هذا طبعا بحسب هيئه الاركان المشتركه
الاوكرانيه ااه هذا من جانب طبعا ايضا
تحدثت عن الجبهه وعن تحرك القتال في
الجبهه وقالت ان القوات الروسيه تحاول من
تحسين وضعها الاستراتيجي في ثلاثه محاور
محور الايمان ومحور باخ مت ومحور همم
هذه الثلاث محاور اساسيه في الديسك وقالت
انه لا يوجد عمليات هجوم او قدره قتاليه
كبيره من قبل الاتحاد الروسي
حتى هذه اللحظات تسيطر على الاوضاع بشكل
جيد على القتال الذي يدور الان هو يدور
حول طريقين استراتيجيين استراتيجيين في
منطقه لوغاز الطريقه الاستراتيجي ب 66 وهو
الذي يربط بالج الروسيه بمنطقه كريمنا هذا
الطريق تحت سيطره القوات الروسيه الان
القوات الاوكرانيه تحاول قطع الامدادات
على القوات الروسيه في هذه المنطقه كذلك
ايضا الطريق الاخر الاستراتيجي الذي يربط
همم منطقه همم بوباص ده ايضا كريمنا وهذا
ايضا يدور حوله قتال من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه للسيطره عليه
طبعا ايضا منطقه خرسون تعرضت لهجوم كبير
وواسع هذا الهجوم نفذ يعني نفذ ب 55 ضربه
صاروخيه الصواريخ هو بانظمات اطلاق
الصواريخ المتعدده وكان هنالك عدد من
القتله والجرح طبعا تعلمنا انه هنالك 51
مسيره اطلقت نحو العاصمه لايف
الجويه ان تسقطها جميعا
بس فقط للتاكيد عدد من تقول اوكرانيا
بانها حيدتهم من الروس
670 او 370 فقط للتوضيح
670 660
هناك معنا عبد الجواد كيف يتم التعاطي مع
هذه الضربه يمكن القول بانها قاسمه بطريقه
او باخرى
لروسيا وهل ربما تكون هذه الانكسارات او
ما ذكر مراسلنا من انه هناك تلمس لعدم
القدره القويه للروس للتعاطي مع التطورات
على الارض هي السبب في ادخال حامله قادفات
جديده الى الجبهه
مساء الخير ميسون لك وليس زملاء نعم
بالفعل هو رقم كبير تتحدث عنه رسميا وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه في بيانها
يعني ابرز ما يحدث هو تداول وسائل الاعلام
الروسيه لهذا الخبر طبعا قتلى كما تحدثت
الدفاع الروسيه بالعشرات العدد وصل الى 30
عسكريا طبعا كانوا في معسكر
والدفاتر كما الاحظ الان في بياناتها
الاخيره بان هذا العدد هو يعني
مدقق والعدد يصل الى ثلاثه و60 جنديا
روسيا كانوا في هذا المعسكر طبعا وسائل
الاعلام الروسيه حتى الان الكثير منها
الصمت رغم الاعلان الرسمي من من وزاره
الدفاع في موسكو لكن طبعا ما يقلق الوضع
هو تحول الحرب على الشريط الحدود ميسون
الى مواجهه في الطائرات من دون طيار
والمسيرات التي طبعا طلقت منها
النابلسيه ليله الامس عدد كبير طبعا
الموضوع بدا اربعه همم مدينه يعني مدينه
افالون جلابيه تقع العاصمه
ال 500 كيلو متر تقريبا وهي تبعد عن
الشريط الكوري المتاح والارضيه الافرانيه
اكثر من 300 كيلو متر طبعا السلطات في تلك
المدينه تحدثت وسائل الدفاع الجوي قامت في
رصد واسقاط مسيره انطلقت من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه طبعا هذا الشيء كان له وقعه
كبير على الشارع الروسي باعتبار ان هذه
المسيره صارت وطارت في الاجواء الروسيه
اكثر من 300 كيلو متر يعني يعني
هناك حديث من قبل الجانب الامريكي
والرئاسه الامريكيه
وهناك نوع من التخوف من ان تصل تلك
المسيرات اللي هي همم امريكا زودتها
لاوكرانيا الى الداخل الروسي وبالتالي
اتساع رقعه همم المعارك اعود الى دوناسك
وطبعا رائد هناك يعطينا فكره عن السير
العمليه في اطار هذه المسيرات رائد
يعني
ميسون بالفعل هناك حسب التصريحات الرسميه
للسلطات هنا بان هناك تقدم روسي في جميع
المحاور وهذا ما دفع الجيش الاوكراني
لاستخدام القصب بالصواريخ الثقيله مثل
صواريخ
لاستهداف القواعد العسكريه هذه المره
الاولى التي تعلن فيها روسيا كما اسلفت
وكما يعني صرح الدفاع عن استهداف القواعد
العسكريه تقول ايضا السلطات المحليه هنا
بانها سيطرت على نسبه 80% من مدينه ماريا
المتاخمه لمدينه دانيه ايضا قوات بادنا
الروسيه كل يوم هناك معطيات عن سيطرتهم
على ربما نقول 100 متر لكن بالنسبه لهم
يقولون بان هناك تضحيات كبيره يقوم بها
جيش الروسي
هذه المساحات وانها بالفعل يعني معارك
ضاريه وليست سهله نحن نسمع اصوات القصب
العنيف الان ما زالت المعارك في كل
المنطقه المنطقه فعلا مشتعله
ونستطيع القول بانه منعطف في المعارك خاصه
في الشرق الاكرانيا وفي مقاطعتين لوجانس
ودانيات همم اريد الحديث ايضا عن المعاناه
الانسانيه اذا سمح الوقت هنا همم انقطاع
في المياه بشكل كبير منذ سته ايام لم تضخ
المياه كانت تضخ ساعتين كل ثلاثه ايام لا
هناك انعدام للمياه في المنطقه ايضا هناك
انقطاع الكهرباء في مقاطعه كثيره القوات
الاوكرانيه قصفت محطات الكهرباء كما تقوم
همم القوات الروسيه بذلك همم
فقط على تلك المنطقه ولكن تتوسع بكل
المناطق تصل الى اكياس بهذا الاطار نتحدث
مع حذيفه حول هذه النقطه تحديدا نتحدث عن
التدفئه نتحدث عن الطاقه بصوره عامه وايضا
المياه
حذيفه هل تسمعني
الانسانيه وكيف انها منتشره في اكثر من
منطقه ومنها كياب لو تحدثنا عن الوضع
الكهرباء في جميع انحاء اوكرانيا وخاصه
العمل عمل الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
بكفاءه في الفتره الاخيره يقلل من الاضرار
في منشات الطاقه وهذا ينعكس ايجابا على
وضع الكهرباء والتدفئه في المدن
الاوكرانيه المختلفه الوضع في وسط البلاد
في العاصمه كيف وفي الولايات الوسط اصبح
اكثر استقرار وكذلك الولايات الشماليه
والولايات الغربيه الان نحن نشهد يعني
حوالي اربعه ايام
في اوقات قليله جدا ولي ساعات قليله همم
جدا حتى الهجوم الاخير لم يسجل اي وصول
وتدمير لاي منشاه المنشات الطاقه كان هناك
همم اصابه طفيفه في احدى محطات الكهرباء
وتم معالجتها بسرعه ومحطه حراريه اخرى
مسؤوله من التدفئه وايضا تم معالجتها
بسرعه وعادت الكهرباء في العاصمه اكيد
ولكن الوضع اشد قسوه في الولايات الشرقيه
في المناطق المتاخمه لامناطق القتال وشرق
وجنوب وجنوب شرق البلاد هنالك الوضع اسوا
خاصه في القرى والمناطق التي تشهد عمليات
عسكريه ولا يمكن الوصول اليها هناك
المعاناه اكبر في هذا الوقت ولكن هنا
الطاقه تشهد استقرار بشكل افضل مراسل
العربيه حذيفه عادل شكرا جزيلا لك من
موسكو عبد الجواد الرشد مراد العربيه شكرا
جزيلا لك ومن دونيتسك مراسل العربيه رائد
الاكبر شكرا جزيلا لك
اسود اسود
في شان العسكري ايضا افاده معهد دراسات
الحرب الامريكي في تقييمه للنزاع الروسي
الاوكراني بان القوات الروسيه تستنفذ
مخزوناتها من ذخيره المدفعيه الثقيله مما
سيجعل من الصعب عليها الحفاظ على الوتيره
العاليه للعمليات في باخمه خصوصا كان رئيس
جهاز المخابرات العسكريه الاوكرانيه قد
صرح بان القوات الروسيه تعاني جراء نقص
ذخيره المدفعيه وقال ان القوات الروسيه
كانت تستخدم سابقا 60,000 قذيفه مدفعيه
يوميا تستخدمه الان 19 الى 20 الف قديفه
فقط اكد رئيس المخابرات الاوكرانيه ان مدى
الورى الروسيه سيتضح بسوره اكبر بحلول
مارس 20 23
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
شلل في العاصمه تونس بسبب اضراب حافلات
النقل
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه نكمل من ايران
وعلى وقع الاحتجاجات المتصاعده اعتقل
الصحفي مهدي قديمي بعد ان اقتحم رجال
الامن الايراني منزل والده في منطقه فرديس
في مدينه كرخ بحسب احد افراد عائلته فان
حوالي 10 من رجال الامن فتشوا غرفته
وسيارته الشخصيه وصادروا هاتفه وحاسبه
المحمول المصدر تحدث عن نقل قديمه الى
طهران بعد فتره وجيزه من القاء القبض عليه
واشار الى ان الفرع الذي يتعامل مع قضيه
مهد القديم هو الفرع الثاني من مكتب
المدعى العام في سجن ايفين
الشرطه في ايران تحذير مالكي سيارات من
عدم الالتزام السيدات على متنها قواعد
اللباس الالزاميه خصوصا وضع الحجاب
استئناف ياتي بعد تعليق القرار في خضم
احتجاجات اعقبت مقتل الفتاه مهساميني بعد
اعتقالها على يد ما يعرف بشرطه الاخلاق
مسؤول في الشرطه اعلن بدء تطبيق المرحله
الجديده من برنامج ناظر واحد في مختلف
انحاء البلاد من دون ذكر تفاصيل اضافيه
اشارت وكاله فارس الايرانيه الى ان
البرنامج يتعلق بمساله خلع الحجاب في
السيارات وكانت رسائل الشرطه سابقا تشير
الى تسجيل مخالفه وتحذر من اجراءات قضائيه
وقانونيه في حاله تكرارها وقد توقفت
الشرطه عن التلويح باتخاذ اجراءات قانونيه
في الرسائل الجديده واكتفت بالدعوه الى
احترام القواعد الاجتماعيه وعدم تكرار
الامر
هذا وقد افادت تقارير محليه بان الحرس
الثوريش ان حمله اعتقالات واسعه في جوان
رود بمحافظه
كرمنشاهده الاغلبيه الكرديه مشيره الى
توتر امني شديد وسط انتشار واسع لقوات
الحرس الثوري الايراني في الشوارع كما
اشارت التقارير الى استمرار استخدام
القوات الحرس الايرانيه للغاز المثير
للدموع على المحتاجين بالاضافه الى اطلاق
الرصاص على المتظاهرين ما ادى الى مقتل
شاب يبلغ من العمر 22 عاما
هذا هو تداول الناشطون ايرانيون على
الانترنت صوره فتاه ايرانيه من منطقه جوان
رود الكرديه في ايران وهي تتحدى مجموعه
كبيره من قوات الامن رافعه شعار النصر
بكله يديها
اما بالنسبه لاحكام الاعدام فتتواصل حيث
حكمت محكمه ساري الايرانيه على المهاراهق
مهدي محمد فرد بالاعدام مرتين وفقا منظمه
رنا الحقوقيه حكم الاعدام مرتين جاء بعدما
واجه الشاب البالغ من العمر 18 عاما تهمه
الافساد في الارض بحسب المحكمه جرى اعتقال
محمد فرد في سبتمبر الماضي اثناء احتجاجات
في مدينه وشهر واتهمته المحكمه انا ذات
باداره والتخطيط الاحتجاجات
ومن المانيا حضر رئيس منظمه الامن
الداخليه الالمانيه توماس هولدين عن ان
النظام الايراني يسعى للحصول على معلومات
عن المعارضين الايرانيين بما في ذلك
المشركون في مسيره برلين التي حضرها
80,000 شخص وقد تناشدت الاستخبارات
الالمانيه ذوي الاصول الايرانيه المعارضين
شدوهم ان يتوخوا الحذر حلا رغبتهم بالسفر
الى ايران
ذكرت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان وزاره
الدفاع طلبت حكومه نتنياهو بزياده
ميزانتها بحوالي 10 مليارات شيكل اي ما
يعادل مليارين و850 مليون دولار قالت
مصادر امنيه اسرائيليه ان هذه الخطوه تاتي
تحضيره لعمل عسكري محتمل ضد ايران وكان
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي الجديد واف جالنت
قد اكد امس انه سيسعى لتامين كل
الاستعدادات المطلوبه اذا اتخذت الحكومه
قرارا بالخيار العسكري ضد ايران
وكان مراسل العربيه في القدس زياد حلبي قد
افاد بان وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه طلبه
زياده في ميزانيتها تحسبا لاي عمل العسكري
ضد ايران حتى وان كان لا يتعلق باي مدى
زمني واضح اشار مراسل العربيه الوجود نقص
في الذخائر العابره للتحصينات وايضا
طائرات التزوج بالوقود في الجيش
الاسرائيلي المتابعه هناك نقص حاليا في
اسرائيل
العابره للتحصينات تحديدا وطائرات تزود
وقود مشكله اسرائيل في هذا الموضوع ليس
اقتناء هذا الامر لان الصفقات تمت مع
الولايات المتحده الولايات المتحده وافقت
على تزويد اسرائيل بهذه التجهيزات لكن
المشكله في الجداول الزمنيه هناك ضغط
اسرائيلي بالتقصير الجداول الزمنيه لانها
تاخذ سنوات احيانا حتى تصل هذه الدقائق
ومؤخرا وقبل قليل او ردنا اخبار عاجله
تصريحات لوزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي الجديد
قال فيها بان اسرائيل ملتزمه بمنع ايران
من حيازه قدرات نوويه عسكريه واضاف ان
اسرائيل ستعمل على تطوير قدراتها العسكريه
المستقله لمواجهه اي سيناريو ايراني وزير
خارجيه اسرائيل الجديد قال بان اسرائيل
تسعى لتشكيل جبهه دوليه لاحباط المشروع
النووي العسكري الايراني واضاف ان اسرائيل
ستسعى لتشكيل هذه الجبهه اذن لاحباط هذا
المشروع
افاده المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان بان
عوده مطار دمشق الدولي للخدمه جزئيه وليست
كليه المرصد اضاف ان المدرج المخصص للشحن
ونقل لقاده الميليشيات بمطار دمشق لا يزال
خارج الخدمه قبل ذلك اعلنت وزاره النقل
السوريه ان المطار يعمل بشكل عادي كانت
الطائرات الاسرائيليه قد استهدفت مواقع
لميليشيا حزب الله اللبنانيه والحارس
الثوري الايراني حيث توجد مستودعات للسلاح
والذخيره وفق المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
الضربات ادت الى مقتل اربعه اشخاص
[موسيقى]
اتهم رئيس حكومه الوحده الليبيه عبد
الحميد خصومه السياسيين بمحاوله اغراق
ليبيا في صراع سياسي لا ينتهي قائلا ان
خالد المشوي عقيله صالح منشغلاني بالتخطيط
لصفقات مشبوهه باي بتعهد في هذا السياق
بالعمل هذا العام على اجراء الانتخابات
وتوحيد المؤسسات الليبيه
ان شاء الله
حام حافل سيكون مطلوبا منا جميعا ان نقف
في دعم اجراء هذه الانتخابات عام 23
سيكونوا عاما
لوحده المؤسسات والقطاعات والمنظمات
المدنيه والشخصيات الوطنيه التي
غايتها
ومطلبها هو الوصول بنا الى الانتخابات
في ما يتعلق
بالتوترات السياسيه بصوره عامه او انه في
استفزاز معين الان دفع دبي لتوجيه هذه
الاتهامات
نعم يا سعود هذه التصريحات التي ضمن
السياق الاتهامات
المتبادله ما بين كل الاطراف السياسيه
سوميس النواب من جهه او مجلس الدوله او
حتى حكومه الوحده الوطنيه الكل يلقي به
اللوم في الطرفه الاخره والطرف الخصم له
على المستوى السياسي بخصوص تعطيل اجراء
الانتخابات وعدم اجرائها للعام الثاني على
التوالي بعد ما كان مقررا ان يتم اجراء
هذه الانتخابات في الرابعه والعشرين من
ديسمبر في عام 20 واحد و20 تستمر هذه
الاتهامات والقاء المسؤوليه واللوم ما بين
الحكومه وما بين مجلسين نواب والدوله كون
ان هناك اتفاق ما بين مجلس النواب والدوله
على ان الحكومه هي المتسبب الرئيسي بترشح
رئيسها في الانتخابات وتعليمها
عن اي صفقات يتحدث على هذا التقارب او
موضوع اخر
رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عبد الحميد
الطيبه لطالما ندت في عديد المرات من رغبه
مجلس النواب ومجلس الدوله بالتمديد
لنفسيهما عبر اجراء بعض التعديلات في
الحكومه من ناحيه وحتى اختيارهم لفتحي
بشاغه كرئيس
الحكومهم بشكل واضح بعدم رغبتهم الصريحه
في اجراء الانتخابات والذهاب الى
الانتخابات وتمديد ميسون المراحل
الانتقاليه وما بدا واضحا في خلال المرحله
الماضيه ولذلك لا يزال الرئيس حكومه
الوحده يسر ويؤكد دائما على هذا الطرح
الذي يرى بان مجلس النواب وهو ما اسم
الدوله ليس هدفهم بالتحديد الاتفاق على
القاعده الدستوريه بل تقاسم السلطه عبر
عمليه اطاله
سنتحدث عن هذا التقارب محمد لانه الان نحن
نعلم انه المجلس الاعلى طبعا للدوله لقد
صوت بالموافقه على استئناف الحوار مع مجلس
الن صوت المجلس على رفض دعوه المجلس
الرئاسي للاجتماع في غدامس والذي كان مقرر
في الحادي عشر من يناير الجاري بحضور رئيس
مجلس النواب عقيل صالح هذا سابقا وايضا
انه بنسابق كان لديك تصريحات ومعلومات
بانه جلسه البرلمان اليوم تبحث الوضع
السياسي واقرار قوانين ويغيب ايضا عن جلسه
البرلمان عقيله صالح فيما ينوب عنه نائب
لرئاسه الجلسه ويناقش النواب موقف
البرلمان من المبادره التي طرحها المجلس
الرئاسه الشهر الماضي تهدف الى التهيئه
لحوار دستورك اولويه لانهاء المراحل
الانتقاليه وحول هذه المعلومات وهذا
التقارب والعوده اذا ما صح التعبير
للتقارب والحوار بين الطرفين همم يكمن
السؤال الكبير البيبي يتحدث عن انه سيفرض
انتخابات وسيعمل على توحيد المؤسسات كل
انه يغني على ليله محمد
كل يغني على ليلاه هو تبدو الانتخابات
الضائعه وسط هذا الغناء لكل الاطراف حتى
هذه اللحظه الان لم يتم توحيد هذه
السيمفونيه ما بين الاطراف السياسيه ويبقى
الشعب منتظر او ينتظر في مصيره لكون عمليه
اجراء الانتخابات هي عمليه حاسمه ومصريه
بالنسبه له من اجل ارتباطها بتغيير كل
منهم في المشهد السياسي الان حديث رئيس
الحكومه لن يتم تحقيقه على ارض الواقعه
وما يعيش الشعب جيده شرقا وغربا وجنوبا
المختص باصدار التشريعات الدستوريه او
قواعد الدستوريه هو الجسم التشريعي متمثله
في مجلس النواب ويتيح له الاتفاق السياسي
او يجبره الاتفاق السياسي لموقع فيها
السيارات على ضروره التشاور مع مجلس
الدوله لذلك يبدو ان حديث رئيس الحكومه
يبدو م- يعني يغرد خارج السرب ان لم يتم
هذه
كل الاجسام السياسيه
نعم تبقى يعني اقرب الحلول هي عمليه
الاتفاق ما بين مجلسي النواب والدوله على
المسارات الثلاثه واهمها مسار قاعده
دستوريه التي كان متوقفا قبل قرار مجلس
الدوله اليوم باستئناف الحوار ميسون ويبقى
ايضا موضوع يعني توحيد السلطه التنفيذيه
هو هاجس ندى كل الليبيين ولكن كل هذه
الحوارات جرت في السابق ما بين بوزقه
المغربيه وما بين العاصمه المصريه القاهره
وتؤدي الى توافق على كل النقاب وتصدم في
النهايه بعقبات محدده وهي ماسه القاعده
السوريه وثلاث مواد او اربع مواد جوهريه
يكمن الخلاف من خلال هذه القاعده
الدستوريه لم يتم همم تجاوزها حتى هذه
المساله المتعلقه بالجنسيه او ترشحا
العسكريين من عدمه في الانتخابات القادمه
لذلك كل التكهنات وكل المعطيات تشير الى
ان كل الحيوانات تؤدي الى نتائج ايجابيه
مبشره ولكن تاتي في الختام ولا تكتمل لعدد
من العقبات
والعراقيل امام القاعده الدستوريه ويامل
المجلسان خلال هذا استئناف للحوار ان يتم
تجاوز هذه العقبه او هاتين العقبتين
بالتحديد سواء مزدوجيه الجنسيهم او حتى
ترشح العسكريين من عدمه تكون ان هناك
اتفاق كبير على كل النقاب المتبقيه
شكرا جزيلا لك
اضراب حركه النقل البري في العاصمه وتوقفت
معها حركه المترو وايضا الحفلات بعد ان
بدا موظفوا شركه النقل الحكوميه اضرابا
للاحتجاج على التاخر في دفع المكافات
والاجور كما تقرر تاجيل الامتحانات في بعض
الجامعات التونسيه تزامنا مع الاضراب في
قطاع النقل
ومن تونس ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه وليد
عبد الله اهلا بك ووليد اعطينا صوره اوضح
عن هذا الاضراب حجمه وبالمقبل اي تحركات
الان ااه للوصول الى حل وسطى على الاقل
وسائل النقل العموم داخل تونس العاصمه
يعني النقل الحضري بشقيه للحافلات وايضا
شركه المترو الخفيف التي توقفت بشكل تام
وتوقف نقله بين محافظات تونس الكبرى
الاربعه منوبه ابن عروس وتونس العاصمه
واريانا وسط غضب شعبي واحتقان لدى
المواطنين الذين قطعت بهم السبل والذين
استقبلوا هذا العام الجديد باول اضراب من
هذا النوع يعني بالحجم الثقيل يعني في
قطاع النقل توقف بالكامل خاصه وان استقبال
السنه الجديده كان يعول عليها التونسي حتى
تتحسن ظروفه عملهم احسن يجدون انفسهم اما
ان يذهبوا الى اماكن عملهم حتى الى
الدراسه سيرا على الاقدام او باستعمال بعض
وسائل النقل العشوائي التي استغل اصحابه
الفرصه غضب والسبب هو
اعوان شركه نقل تونس لعدم حصولهم على
اجورهم ومن ناحيهم لاخر السنه
الاكل واحتجاجا على الوضعيه المهنيه التي
اصبحت متردده الشركه
رغم التحول عدد كبير من منظور شركه نقل
تونس الى ساحه الحكومه بالقصبه قباله مقر
الحكومه التونسيه للضغط على الحكومه وزاره
النقل بالتدخل وصرف الاجور وباقي مستحقات
همم المهنيين في القطاع الا انه الى حدود
هذه اللحظه لا شيء ثابت على ان هناك
اتفاقا قد يحصل من اجل رفع هذا الاضراب
الذي شلت بموجبه الحركه تماما وجه الزيدي
كتب عام جامعه النقل التي دعت منظرها الى
هذا الاضراب يقول انه في هذا الاضراب الى
اجل غير مسمى حتى يتم الاستجابه لمطاله
مستحقاتهم شركه نقل تونس تقول المتحدث
باسمها انها تعاني صعوبه ماليه بسعوبات
ماليه كبرى ولا يمكن ان تحل المشكله في
الوقت وهو ما يعني تواصل لهذا الاضرار
الذي هي من المنتظر ان تعقبه اضرابات اخرى
25 او 26 جانفي من هذا النهارده في
القطاعات الثلاثه للنقل في تونس يعني برا
وبحرا وجوا بمطالب مهنيه ونظرا ليتردى
القطاع العام وليد عبد الله شكرا جزيلا لك
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
لاول مره منذ ثلاث سنوات امبراطور اليابان
يلقي خطابا عاما للجماهير بمناسبه العام
الجديد
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه اعلن تنظيم
داعش مسؤوليته عن هجوم على قوات حركه
الطالبان في العاصمه الافغانيه كابول امس
وكان انفجار واقعه خارج المطار العسكري في
كابول واسقط العديد من الضحايا وفقا
لوزاره الداخليه التي تديرها طالبان
وقد نظم عدد من النشطاء مظاهره حاشده في
العاصمه واشنطن امام البيت الابيض رفضا
لحضر طالبان النساء الافغانيات من دخول
الجامعه
فريزر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فليغيره
نشرت كوريا الجنوبيه صورا لاطلاق صاروخ
فضائي يعمل بالوقود الصلب وافادت وكاله
انباء كوريا الجنوبيه
بان هذه التجربه هي الثانيه من نوعها بعد
ما اجرت الاولى في مارس الماضي التجربه
بعد رفع القيود الامريكيه لتطوير الصواريخ
في كوريا الجنوبيه بما في ذلك استخدام
الوقود الصلب
الرئيس الكوري الجنوبي من جانبه قال ان
بلاده والولايات المتحده تخططان لتدريبات
النوويه لمواجهه التهديدات النوويه
والصاروخيه لكوريا الشماليه التصريحات
تزامنت مع تهديدات كوريا الشماليه بتطوير
الترسانتها النوويه لمواجهه التهديدات
الولايات المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه على حد
تعبير بيومك
ين تشعلوا شبه الجزيره من جديد تدريبات
عسكريه تقوم بها كوريا الجنوبيه مع حلفتها
الاولى الولايات المتحده لم تتوقف عند حد
تدريبات دوريه بل تطرحوا الان فكره
مناورات نوويه مشتركه بهدف الربع
بالاشاره الى الجاره الشماليه وذلك بحسب
صحيفته
والتي نقلت المعلومات عن الرئيس الكوري
الجنوبيون المظله النوويه
لم تعد تكفي لطمئنه الكوريين الجنوبيين
تصريحات بلورتها وزاره الدفاع في كوريا
الجنوبيه بشكل اوضح مشدده على الردع
تهديدات كوريا الشماليه من خلال تعزيز
نظام البلاد الدفاع الثلاثي المحور وهو
برنامج الاستهداف في قياده عدو مفرد في
حاله الطوارئ بالاضافه الى النظام الدفاع
جوي وصاروخي
سيبني جيشنا وضعيه الاستعداد العسكري للرد
بشده على اي استفزازات كوريه شماليه
واظهار العزم على عدم التردد في خوض الحرب
الاخيره فقد وجهتهامات لامريكا بمحاوله
تشكيل نسخه اسيويه
الاساسيتين كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
متواعدا بتطوير الترسانه بلاده النوويه
الى عمر العربيه
عدد الحياء الى طبيعتها في بعض المدن
الصينيه الرئيسيه منها بكين شنغهاي ووهان
وذلك مع تخفيف السلطات خيوط كورونا ولم
تمنع درجات الحراره المنخفضه لم تمنع
المواطنين من الخروج الى الشوارع المتابعه
[موسيقى]
ياتي هذا في وقت اعلنت فيه قطر فرضا تقديم
نتيجه سلبيه لاختبار كورونا على جميع
المسافرين القادمين من الصين اعتبارا من
الغد وكاله الانباء الرسميه ذكرت انها شرط
الاختبار المفروض على جميع المسافرين بغض
النظر عن التطعيم وكانت دول عده قد فرضت
قيودا على المسافرين القادمين من الصين
بسبب تزايد اعداد اصابات هناك فيما اعلن
المغرب حضره دخول لجميع القادمين من الصين
بغض النظر عن جنسياتهم
من الصين الى اليابان ولاول مره منذ ثلاث
سنوات القى الامبراطور الناروهيتو خطابا
عاما للجماهير بمناسبه العام الجديد في
الوقت الذي تخفف فيه البلاد من القيود
المفروضه لمكافحه كورونا نتابعه
خلاص
[موسيقى]
شكرا ميسون واهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
يصلوا الليله اللاعب البرتغالي كريستيانو
رونالدو الى العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
قديما من مدريد تمهيدا للاعبي مع نادي
النصر السعودي وينتظر ان يقدم النادي
لاعبه الجديد الى الجماهير غدا الثلاثاء
في ملعب مرسول مباركا وسط حضور الجماهرين
واعلاميين كبير من داخل السعوديه وخارجها
وبحسب صحيفه الرياضيه المتخصصه سيلقي
كريستيانو رونالدو خلال الحفل كلمه قصيره
يخاطب فيها جماهير ناديه الجديد
وصلنا نحو الاسطوره البرازيلي بلاي الى
ملعب نادي سانتوس حيث سيبدا النادي الذي
لعب له الراحل معظم مسيرته مراسم التشييع
في الملعب اليوم الاثنين وستقوم الجماهير
بالقاء النظره الاخيره على بيليه لمده 24
ساعه وبعد انتهاء مراسم القاء النظره
الاخيره سيمر موكب الجنازه عبر شوارع
سانتوس
انطلقت اليوم المرحله ذكرى المقامه حاليا
في السعوديه للعام الرابعه على التوالي
مسافه المرحله الثانيه وصلت الى
5089 كيلومترا وبدات من ينبع الى العلا
ونجح المتسابق السابق لاين بخط في صداره
فئه الدراجات من الامريكيه ركبرا بيك فيما
تصدر القطري ناصر العطيه المرحله الثانيه
لفئه السيارات فيراري ذكر
بكار الحقيقه من اهم الفعاليات اللي احنا
نقيمها في المملكه العربيه السعوديه زي ما
انتم الان شاهدتم بانفسكم كيف كبروا العدد
المشاركين كل هالابطال وكل ها الفرق من
انحاء العالم تيجي عشان تحاول انها تنافس
وتثبت نفسها على ارض المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بانها قادر ان تخوض اصعب
الراليات واكبر الراليات واهم على الاطلاق
وهو رالي دكار همم السعوديه اسماء اكبر
اسماء موجوده اهم الاسماء في عالم
الرياضيات موجوده في ارض حقيقه يعني تعطيل
كثير للراليات شاهدنا اا خلال الاربع سنين
الماضيه همم
مناطق جدا جميله مناطق جدا همم همم يعني
همم
مخصصه للراليات في التنوع الجغرافي ما
تلقى في اي بلد ولا اي مكان الا الحمد لله
بلد مثل المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ولا تاخذ يعني كلام يعني اسال من السابقين
كيف يشوفوا المنافسه كيف شافه الحمد لله
الترتيبات التجهيزات اللي يقدمها المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في جميع همم
المناسبات فهي بشهاده الجميع لله الحمد
افضل نسخ دكار على الاطلاق
اللي في المملكه العربيه السعوديه نشوف
السنه هذه انتقلنا في مناطق جديده همم
كانت البدايه من ينبع والنهايه هتكون في
في المنطقه الشرقيه
انطلاقى الجوله الحاديه عشره من الدوري
المصري لكره القدم يلتقي الليله النادي
الاهلي مع ضيفه بيراميدز على استاد
القاهره الدولي ويحتل الاهلي المركز
الثاني باربع 20 نقطه ويسعى الى مصالحه
جماهيره بعد التعادل في اخر مباراهتين
بينما يحتل بيراميدز المركز الرابع برصيد
20 نقطه الموسم الماضي انتقل لفريقان ثلاث
مرات حيث يتغلب الاهلي في ذهاب مسابقه
الدوري وخسر ايابا ونجح الاهلي بالفوز على
منافسه في الدور ربع النهائي لمسابقه كاس
مصر لكره القدم
لحساب الجوله التاسعه عشر من الدوري
الانجليزي الممتاز لكره القدم يستقبل برنت
فورد الليله نادي ليفربول
وسيدخل الفريق بمعنويات عاليه هذه
المباراه بعد الفوز على ليستر سيتي بهدفين
بهدف واحد في الجوله الماضيه ويملك فريق
المدرب يورجن كلوب 28 نقطه مقابل 23 ابطال
افريقيا برنت فورد
وتعرض لتوتنا للخساره امام استون فيلا
بهدفين دون مقابل ضمن منافسات الاسبوع
الثامن عشر من الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز
لكره القدم بهذه النتيجه
الى احدى 20 نقطه فيما تجمد رصيد وتوتنهام
عندها 30 نقطه حتى الان
شهدت الجوله العاشره من الدوري الاسترالي
لكره القدم فوز ادي الاي دو يونايتد على
بيرث جلوري بهدفين مقابل لا شيء او
الاهداف اللقاء كان في الدقيقه الاربعين
من زمن اللقاء واضاف حال لوران الهدف
الثاني لفريقه في الدقيقه الثانيه
والسبعين بهذه النتيجه ارتفع رصيده ادي
لايدي الى 15 نقطه وتجمد رصيد عند سبع
نقاط
[تصفيق]
ونجح فريق ميلبورنا سيتي بالفوز على
ولينكتون بثلاثه اهداف مقابل هدف واحد في
الدوري الاستراليه سجل اهداف كول الهدف
الاول لفريقه
السادسه عشر قبل ان يعادل ماثيو ليكي
النتيجه لمصلحه ميلبرن سيتي بعدها بدقيقه
الحاديه والخمسين وعد اللاعب هو نفسه احرز
ثاني اهدافه وثالث لفريق بورن والذي رفع
رصيده الى اثنتين و20 نقطه من 9 المباراه
الدوري الاسرائيلي لكره القدم
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لكم على حسن
المتابعه وعوده اليك ميسون
[موسيقى]
شكرا
من الاسر النازحه في الحديده اليمنيه من
نقص الغذاء والمواد الاساسيه التي تمكنهم
من العيش الكريم داخل المخيمات وضع دفع
هذه الاسر الى امتحان بعض الاعمال الشاقه
من اجل الحصول على ما يسد رمق الاطفال بعد
ان هجرتهم مليشيات الحوثي من المنازل
المتابعه
على علب البلاستيك هذه يعتمد في اعاده
اسرته باكرا لجمع نحو 50 علبه
لسد جوع اطفاله في مخيم النيابه وضعوا عبد
الله احمد كحالي عشرات النازحين الذين
هجرتهم من منازلهم في الحديده وتعز غربي
اليمن
هربنا من الحسين
ااه تصعيب المعيشه ومن كل حاجه نعاني من
كل حاجه وبحسب تقرير الامم فان اكثر من
مليون شخص نزحوا من محافظه الحديده بسبب
الانتهاكات الحوثيه وارتفعت موجه النزوح
خلال نوفمبر الماضي الى اكثر من 70%
لتكتظو مخيمات النزول في المناطق المحرره
بالحديده والمخاء باكثر من 800 عائله قصص
ماساويه تعيشها الاسر النازحه داخل هذه
المخيمات بعد ان هجرتهم الميلشات الحوثيه
من منازلهم في خطوط التماسي الحرب معاناه
تختزلوا بؤس الحياه في ظل الحرب الحوثيه
قال سعيد العربيه من مخيم العليلي
الجنوبيه الحديده
وجه ملك الاردن عبد الله الثاني الحكومه
بتجميد الضريبه على الكيروسين في فصل
الشتاء لتخفيف الاعباء عن المواطنين قال
ديوان الملكي الاردني ان هذه التوجيهات
جاءت خلال لقاء الملك مع وجهاء واهالي
محافظه العقبه وممثلين عن قطاعات مختلفه
فيها اشارت الى ان القرار ياخذوا في
الحسبان اعتماد عدد كبير من المواطنين
الاردنيين على الكرسيين في اغراض التدفئه
خلال الشتاء
حولت الاوراق الرسميه او الشخصيه حياته
عراقيين الى جحيم اذ يعاني قرابه المليون
شخص من هذه المشكله في البلاد اكثر من
نصفهم من الاطفال الامر الذي ينعكس على
الخدمات الاساسيه المقدمه لهم كالتعليم
وايضا الصحه
لكن الاهالي يدركون ذلك جيدا
بدرس وما اطلع لونها وياك هويتي بعدها
يعني خلي يقول اني اول ما تطلقه
ما عندي هاي ما عندي مكاني ابدلهم يعني
في العراق
الاساسيه كالتعليم والصحه الازمه تعود الى
فتره سيطره تنظيم داعش للتخشي السلطات من
شبهات الانتماء للتنظيم اضافه الى ازمه
اثبات واطفال ولد وقتها ففي بعض الاحيان
تتطلب شهاده الميلاد الى فحص الحمض النووي
وهو ما لا يمكن تحقيقه في بعض الاحيان
اخرون فقده هويتهم اثناء الفرار من معارك
الموصل عرضهم ذلك لمشاكل كبيره يحاول
بعضهم لاصدار بطاقه شخصيه
النزوح ضاعت الهويه عندي
خمس اشهر حسب التعذيب وطلعت براءه حسب
قاضي وهاي والمختار المنطقه الشهود طلعت
براءه
وانا متزوج بزمن متزوج وعندي ووليد
والاولاد ما عنده لا هويه ولا عندي عقد
زواج شيفته
في الاموال من جهه اخرى
2019 وحتى منتصف العام الماضي
الخمسه انتهت شكرا لمتابعه مشاهدينا
ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]